hi everyone my name is Daniel botsman I
teach Japanese history here at Yale
and it is an incredible privilege today
to be able to welcome to campus Miss
tushko Tanaka and her daughter missio
in addition to thanking them both for
being here and for making the long
exhausting Journey from Japan to the
east coast I do also want to express my
deep gratitude to Anthony shimamoto from
the University of Connecticut School of
Law and Takeshi Watanabe from Wesleyan
University for arranging their visit and
opening up this extraordinary
opportunity to us here at Yale
as I'm sure you all know tanakasam
brings today a message of the greatest
importance one that is hard to believe
anyone in the world after 1945 could
ever forget
and yet according to the bulletin of the
atomic scientists we now live in a time
of unprecedented Danger
so-called Doomsday Clock set at just 90
seconds to midnight
the closest we've ever been in other
words to True Global catastrophe
and of course all over the world we've
seen the continued proliferation of
nuclear weapons
as those of you who attended last week's
John W Hall lecture by the eminent
political scientist Richard Samuels from
MIT know
today even in Japan
the only country in the world to have
experienced the horrors of a nuclear
attack
politicians are openly discussing the
acquisition of nuclear weapons in order
they say
to counter the threats of North Korea
and China
here at Yale I'm glad to say that there
have been those over the years who have
written and spoken about the horrors
that befell the people of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in August 1945.
to give just two prominent examples
John Hersey who served as head of
Pearson College from 1965 to 1970 and
taught writing here for almost 18 years
may have done more than any other
American to make ordinary people in this
country aware of the horrors of the
nuclear bombings with his Landmark 1946
essay Hiroshima
50 years later in 1996 John treat only
recently retired from the East Asian
languages and literatures Department
published his important book writing
Ground Zero Japanese literature and the
atomic bomb
so important that we have access to
works like these that describe on the
page what happened
but it's one thing to be able to read
about the horror it is quite another to
be able to hear directly from someone
who lived through it
in this regard I can only say again what
a truly special privilege it is for us
to have Tanaka toshikosang here with us
today
please join with me now in extending her
the very warmest possible welcome
first of all my mother and I would
really thank you for having us here
today
you'd especially like to extend our
sincere gratitude
to the people and organizations who made
this event possible
my name is
I'm from Japan
I'm a second generation hibakusha or a
bomb Survivor
since I was a child I have believed that
nuclear weapons cannot coexist with
Humanity
my mother once told me that when I was
born the first thing my father had to do
was count my fingers and toes
to make sure that I had no birth defect
in those days even though people
survived themselves they had to worry
about radiation damage to their children
I would first give a brief overview of
the damage caused by the atomic bomb on
Hiroshima then my mother toshiko will
tell your her story and we will have a
question and answer session afterward
during the talk we would like to share
some of the photos of toshiko's enamel
mural Works which she has created for
over 50 years
putting her wishes for peace
we would like to give you a prior
warning
some of the pictures and stories being
shared might cause some of you
discomfort and you might decide whether
you would prefer to avoid them
skipped yes
on August 6 1945 at 8 15 am the atomic
bomb was dropped targeting a bridge at
the center of Hiroshima City the bomb
exploded 2 000 feet
above the ground releasing intense Heat
blast and radiation
near the hypocenter the blast is
believed to have had a speed of about 1
000 feet per second
buildings which were mostly made of wood
at the time collapsed over a wide area
people were blown away by the tremendous
blast
at the moment of explosion the
temperature near the center was believed
to be between 5400 and 7200 Fahrenheit
this is a picture of Stone steps at the
entrance of a bank
the intense heat turned the steps
whitish
and the stone under the person sitting
there waiting for the bank to open
remained dark
this tricycle belonged to a
three-year-old boy
who died in the attack while he was
playing on his favorite toy his tricycle
considering the iron melt at 2700
Fahrenheit people's skin who were
outside near the hypocenter must have
been chuckled
instantly
the atomic bomb differs from other bombs
because it emits radiation which causes
cellular and genetic abnormalities
the vast majority of people exposed to
radiation within 0.6 miles died even if
they were unharmed
also many people are believed to be
damaged by exposure to residual
radiation from The Fallout so-called
deadly Ash and rain mixed with
radioactive materials so-called Black
Rain
radiation can cause various long-term
diseases such as leukemia thyroid cancer
breast cancer and colorectal cancer
even now it's affecting many people
although the exact number is still
unknown
140 000 people in Hiroshima and over 70
000 people in Nagasaki estimated have
died by the end of the year
on July 2017 a global agreement on to
ban nuclear weapons known as the treaty
on the prohibition of nuclear weapons or
tpnw was adopted at the United Nations
which entered into a force on January
22nd 2021.
before the treaty's adoption nuclear
weapons were the only weapons of mass
destruction not subject to a
comprehensive ban despite their
humanitarian and environmental
consequences
it prohibits nations from developing
testing producing manufacturing
transferring processing stockpiling
using or threatening to use nuclear
weapons or allowing nuclear weapons to
be stationed on their territory
it also prohibits them from assisting
encouraging or inducing anyone to engage
in any of these activities
the Nobel Prize peace prize 2017 was
awarded to the international campaign to
abolish nuclear weapons or I can for its
work to draw attention to the
catastrophic humanitarian consequences
of any use of nuclear weapons or for its
groundbreaking efforts to achieve a
treaty-based Prohibition of such weapons
there are now 13 000 nuclear warheads in
the world which is enough
to wipe out every living thing on the
planet multiple times over
more than 90 percent of them belong to
the United States and Russia
my mother and I are here to speak to you
not because we want you to make you feel
guilty or sorry
but because we hope that we can work
together
to create a more peaceful world
the average age of Hiroshima Hibachi in
Hiroshima is now over 84 years old
my mother is also 84.
in the near future
we will not be able to hear directly
from them
so let's invite toshiko to share her
story
[Applause]
hello my name is
I survived the ethnic bombing in
Hiroshima Hiba Christian is how we call
all the survivors in Japanese
I've been creating enamel mirror artwork
for over 50 years
it wasn't easy for me to talk about but
I'm going to tell you today
I tried not to remember what had
happened in Hiroshima on August 6 1945.
I thought people would not understand me
I would not ever to talk to anybody
about my personal experience of the
academic bombing not even to my own
family
I started to open up and share this
horrible this experience when I turned
70.
it is a miracle for me to be able to
tell you my story today
hopefully we are all here to stop
something like this
thing
originally my family lived only 500
meters
540 yards from Ground Zero whereas a
bank hit
but just one week before the atomic
bombing we moved
2.3 kilometers away
1.4 miles away from Ground Zero
because of this I am alive today
even though I was burned and exposed to
radiation
when I was just 60 years old
the gigantic mushroom crowd was right
above me
at 8 15 am I was on my way to school
somebody shouted
I looked up and saw a tremendous brush
this was like a million likes
everything went white
I couldn't see
I covered my face with my right arm
heat burnt my head my neck and my right
arm
then suddenly everything went dark like
night time
hot sand dust blew up it
I couldn't see but the dust crowd was
like a giant mushroom
my mouth was full of dust
what is happening what should I do I
can't well I get that terrible crunchy
sounded taste
soon my burnt arm began to swell the
pain was incredible
I cried
all the way home
our house was very damaged
when I got there
even though my mother was alive
she could not recognize me my hair was
burnt I was covered as my girls was
destroyed
that night I would cause to death
many doctors were dead
there were no hospitals left
Survivor depended on how strong you were
and how lucky
my younger sister had bad head wounds
my father was away in the army
our roof was mostly gone
but suddenly I looked up and thought
small patch of blue sky
although I was in pain I thought this is
so beautiful
that blue sky stayed with me it had
given me the will to live
as if the heavens said don't worry there
will be a tomorrow
this is why I continue to live life
positively even through many hardships
it took only one second for a single
bomb to destroy the city of Hiroshima
and 1040
000 lives
and another bomb to kill seventy
thousand more in Nagasaki
all my classmates were killed
my young earned left home that money
and never came back
was never found
every image of that terrible day
remained
my generation will be the last to tell
you I but this event as a direct
Witnesses
this is what I saw
after I got home that day I saw a large
crowd of dying people
they were working in procession near my
house somewhere opened
men women and children alike were almost
naked with burnt clothes
they worked in silence without stretched
arms
fingers
they are like ghosts
even today whenever I see barbecued
Tomatoes it
it reminds me
of that terrible thing of death
like tomatoes human skin peels off
easily when wound
I have another strong memory of that
time
I was unconscious for a few days
when I woke up there was a strong smell
in the air
it would like burning rotten fish
even now I can still smell it
but the smell wasn't the fish
it would
smell of it's a smell of the human
bodies being cremated in City books and
the school grounds
even though our family had nothing
my mother sheltered many people in our
house
one was her cousin Kenzo matsuki
he came to our house with a burnt bucket
continued the score of a woman he wishes
to bury
the score belonged to his end
his aunt was burned alive in her own
house
people around the home noted to do
anything because she was
trapped battery
in the burning house
the the service had to escape to Empire
begged for her forgiveness while
deducting her
I also remember a 15 older girl who came
to our house
on her back she carried her badly burned
younger sister
the burned girl survived but the older
God did not she had been exposed to
massive radiation
my husband's include an English teacher
and a devouted Christian he used to
paint beautiful pictures and believed in
peace
him
and all his six family members
greeting his baby
grieving their loss my husband adopted
his uncle's a family name
Taka
my husband has now died but I still
carry this last name
in those days the city of Hiroshima
a surface of the rivers which run
through the city were entirely covered
by people's bodies
did
there were also 12 Young American
prisoners of war in Hiroshima
they also died from the back dropped by
their own country
later something weird weird started to
happen in Hiroshima
people with no injuries started to die
no one knew them but they had been
exposed to massive radiation
exactly how much radiation the ethnic
virus produced is still unknown
do you know the famous story of Sadako
and her paper cranes
Sadako was four years younger than me
went the same
survived the atomic bombs
he was two years old
die of leukemia at the age to Europe
there were many other children like
Sadako
in my case radiation symptoms started
red nodes
to Europe
my white blood cell count was abnormal
I suffered constant fever and fatigue
and sometimes painted
I always had Mouse answered and brushes
around my mouth it's hard to eat
even today when I am very tired
I I have pain
ful source and can't sleep
I sometimes bleed from my color
I have had three ribs broken
arjury and the cataract surgery
the Japanese government decided to
certify Atomic victims only origin two
kilometers
1.24 mile radius of ground zero
since
Beyond this radius my symptoms are not
officially satisfied as atomic bomb
relatives
some other victims have tried to sue the
government but instead I decided to
spend the rest of my life on my Earth
and testimony
for more than six years after the end of
the war
the American government hit the
radiation damage by blocking the media
in those days the country was competing
against the USSR
in its nuclear arms development and
wanted to carry out numerous nuclear
tests
this would also development nuclear
power generation
to the name of peaceful utilization
so the damage caused by radioactivity
but uncomfortable Truth for the
government
so without knowing citizen drank
contaminated water and Aid vegetables
grown in contaminated grounds
later many relatives and friends died
from leukemia
and other forms of cancer
those days hibacha also suffered this
nation in Japanese Society
in those those days Hibachi women had
trouble marrying
because their babies often had bus
defect
fortunately I was able to marry and had
a happy family life
my husband did not mind did not seem to
mind
that I was a hibakisha but when a first
child record was born he was scared he
seriously checked the baby's fingers and
toes
then I realized that he had been worried
about
damage of the bomb on a baby
not just my husband but all parents
those days were worried
up until now they are still had not been
enough research on the impact of
radioactivity on the second generation
no doctors can give any legitimate
diagnosis there is no proof that the
second generation can maintain their
health
the hibakusa continued to feel sorry for
their children
and have to have to carry this
psychological body for their entire life
before the bomb our family line
generally had been blessed
health
however after the bomb three of my
sister's daughters
who are second generation hibakusa were
Afflicted with thyroid disease
one of them had surgery to remove
thyroid cancer at the age of 22. my
younger brother who is also a second
generation hibakusha had surgery to
remove colon cancer when she would still
quite Young
doctors say there is no evidence to
connect these diseases to
it but
the high possibility of side effects of
the bombing
nobody on this planet should suffer this
same tragedy
since 2007 I have made four round World
voyages on this boat which is sponsored
pitched japan-based International Energy
of
I learned more about the situation of
the world during these voyages I have
visited more than 80 countries including
ones that are suffering tragic world
and the one that
damage from crime change
I learned that nuclear weapon will lead
us to destruction
they are inhumane and should never be
allowed on Earth
in 2009 Dr Kathleen Sullivan and Mr
Robert kronkist who are the founders of
NY based NGO used at New York's
hibakisha stories
initiative
kindly invited me and gave me the
opportunity to share my testimony with
students in high schools and colleagues
in New York and Oklahoma
and since I had made 12 visits in seven
years with their program
the program had reached more than 50
000 more thousand students and citizens
during that testimony
sometimes used by enamor as well
I believe
artist
a powerful tool for peace education
one day a junior high school student in
New York City
who joined the Hibachi stories program
asked me
why I made a friend with Americans even
though I was nearly killed by the atomic
bomb
I answer what this
during the war Japanese people were
taught to believe
that all within us were demons
in the beginning
it was very hard to forgive them
for all the suffering caused by the farm
but I now believe
that hatred only creates a change of
hatred
and it will eventually lead to killings
and distraction by War
humankind needs to make every effort to
cut off this chain of hydrate and
instead have loved throughout Humanity
as a whole
in 2010 I studied to take part in in a
campaign in which we visit local
officials throughout Japan
and collected their signatures agreeing
to support the anti-nuclear policy I
also created an earth piece for an
enduclear adult project
on March 11th 2000
11. there were a series of incidents a
nuclear power plant information Japan
I feel the strong urge to learn why
these things are happening
in
2012. I joined a project to visit the
areas damage damaged by the turnover
nuclear power plant disaster in Ukraine
in 1986 and its neighboring country
below
at the Chernobyl plant the commission
work had been going on for nearly 30
years
but they said they might need 40 or 100
more years to finish it
our government has not learned from
either the tragedy on digox
or the alternative disaster
was a tuna fishing boat food 23 crew
members were exposed to nuclear forward
or a nuclear test
carried out by the U.S in 1954 at bikini
at all
instead the Japanese government
continues to produce
radioactive substances which will create
even more victims of radiation
during so
they are also depriving their own
citizens of food and
expresso
the leap praise to live we do not know
when the disaster in Fukushima will end
there are many people working tirelessly
for a new career free world for instance
Ikea is a global campaign to promote the
abolishment of nuclear weapons
on July 7th
2017 the world the essentials step it is
needed to add peace
however none of nuclear states and their
allies including Japan
has
has supported
the treaty
I urge the leaders of the new nuclear
weapon States and other
nations not the dismissed tpnw
I did they stick
but to listen to the voice of people
read the treaty and think about it again
and please think about creating peace
not going to go
nuclear weapons do not deter War
Russia itself is now proven this point
last year in 2010 22 Russian President
Putin State started the world in Ukraine
Ukraine and suggesting the use of
nuclear weapons
for a Survivor who knows the inhumane
tragedy caused by those weapons
this is totally unacceptable and I feel
strong anger and frustrated that
personally could not do anything
then I received a video message from
Miss Tamara
whom I had met 10 years earlier
in my in my visit to Ukraine
she strongly asked me
Survivor
you have to keep telling the world
about the terrible things that would
happen if nuclear weapons were used
empowered by her message
and with the support of this boat and
Hiroshima based energy and Hiroshima I
give a talk on Russian YouTube channel
last year
I hope that hibakisha's voice has
reached Russian people
in November last year my daughter and
Iva invited to speak at an International
Conference held at otago University in
New Zealand
I realized realist how seriously the
nuclear issues are in
impacting impacting the southern
Hemisphere and Global South through
problems including nuclear test testing
nuclear waste
or also
they were developed and used by the
countries of global North
and that the issues
now now
cannot be solved only by the global
North
we must work together as a global
Community to solve these problems
during World War II
then U.S president Harry Truman decided
to drop atomic bombs without a second
thought he said it was necessary in
order to end the world quickly
but It is believed that the real reason
was to send a message to the USSR
one of the soldiers who developed
foreign
you know what
truma who is a grand grandson of Harry
truma and aribiza who is a grandson of
Jacob Visa
both good friends of mine today
Ari visited me often we actually met
recently
and spend a good time together
both Clinton and Arya are working very
hard towards creative wilderpiece
we were still
at all
I would be enemies
close friends from around the world
we will think twice before starting out
that just seek personal prosperity and
Supremacy
empathy is an essential trait
for policy makers and citizens alike
in the post Japan caused the
a
other requests votes on aggression that
lift
tremendous damage
especially on countries in Asia
the Japanese people must
reflect on this
when the atomic Obamas were dropped
people in North East Asia thought
now we are freed
however
the use of nuclear weapons
shocked the world
by
creating a different
Devastation that changed the concept of
War
when I apologize to my Malaysian friend
for the Japanese militaries
arthrologists
behaviors in the past
he said I don't expect you to apologize
to me now
but I want you to remember what had what
happened
in the past
let's try our best
to prevent
another one from happening
he is a person whose grandfather was
killed by Japanese soldiers
we as a student must not create
readers of a country that start
were for for the sake of
territorial
better
it will lead to an arms race
an inventory to the use of nuclear
weapons which will cause
horrible diversity Devastation and the
end of the world
we are the crew members
of a ship called
planet Earth
if the crew members fight each other for
food and good place the ship eventually
Drift Away
And We Sip worked wrecked and none of us
will survive
now is the time for the world to help
each other
create the peace through diplomacy
to conclude my story I have one request
for you the Young Generation
please choose the past to coexist
regardless of your differences including
nationality and race
the future there are disputes among the
Nations please try to solve them
with words
instead of words
once we start to watch we can only eat
other
as enemies
not as humans
and weaker kill enemies with ease
nuclear weapons will lead the Earth to
distraction they are inhumane and
should never be allowed on us
I know one day we will live in a nuclear
free world
and the Beautiful Blue Sky will continue
to shine above the heads of our future
generation thank you for your kind
attention I will be happy answer your
thank you
thank you so much thank you so much to
both of you for coming to speak with us
and thank you so much for sharing your
story
um yeah I'm very moved by it
um and it yeah it means a lot that you
came to speak with us so thank you my
question is a bit
departing from your story about the
nuclear bomb itself or the atomic bomb
and more about I mean you're one of the
last generation who will remember and
who was there for the bombing
um but you're also one of the last
Generations who remembers how the city
was like before the bombing
um and I'm wondering if there's anything
that you'd like us to remember or carry
about the city before
um the bomb the city the people
um they'd like us to carry with us thank
you
um
foreign
uh so
um someone once said that um when they
went to Hiroshima that they saw the
peace Park in the in the middle of the
city and they said oh it's a good thing
that the bomb fell on a park
um without understanding the reality
which was that in fact that was the
center of the city where ordinary people
made their lives
um and that was of course completely
destroyed and changed as a result of the
dropping of the bomb
so uh
that person's kind of misunderstanding
was suggestive of
um of the enormity of what happened
and
um
so the place where the um the peace
Memorial now stands in Hiroshima is
precisely where her kindergarten was
um and uh so she was supposed to
graduate from the kindergarten go to the
school all of her classmates who
attended that school died in the bomb
sorry
[Music]
so it was
um a beautiful town and
um of course in many ways there were
lots of fun things about the town but as
a result of all of her classmates dying
it also became a place that she never
could go again
thank you
thank you thank you so much for this
inspiring speech it's very powerful and
like sometimes I just almost bring tears
to my eyes and I really appreciate this
opportunity so um I'm sure an audience
really get your inner strengths and
that's what I'm thinking how you can
share with the younger generation you
know enter this kind of a circumstance
how would it make you to stand up in the
middle of this Darkness
paying what keep you be still be so
hopeful and strong uh really how you
build your resilience and inner
strengths and peace that's what I want
to know if you can share with our
audience especially younger generation
thank you so much
foreign
was dropped and the City was destroyed
she as a child remembers looking up at
the sky and seeing that it was this
beautiful blue sky and even though her
body was in pain she and all of the
adults were of course unable to look at
something like the sky but as a child
she could look up and see this guy and
think oh it's the same sky as yesterday
if yesterday's sky is here then
tomorrow's Sky will be here there will
be a tomorrow
and having lived for 84 years you know
she's experienced all sorts of Trials
and difficult things but she's always
felt that she knows that tomorrow will
come there'll be a better tomorrow
so I think that's
like everyone else I want to say thank
you so much for sharing your story it
was really moving and my question is
that you mentioned how you didn't tell
your story until you were 70 and so I
wanted to ask how did you make that
decision
um why did it take so long and how did
you then decide that you wanted to tell
the world
foreign
[Music]
so when she was younger
um her feeling was that um even if she
talked about what happened she wouldn't
really be able to have no one would be
able to understand who hadn't actually
lived through it
um and she also felt that
[Music]
um
she didn't want to remember
the because all of her classmates had
died she didn't want to have to think
about it
um and she felt
um also that uh some kind of discomfort
towards the
um
so when she was 70 the thing that
changed was she went on the peace boat
to South America to Venice
and in Venezuela
a mayor in one of the towns she visited
said as somebody who lived through this
you have an obligation a responsibility
to to talk about it
um and she decided that if she had a
responsibility to speak about it then
perhaps the people who died would be
able to forgive her for speaking about
it
um this horrible thing that had happened
to them so that became the the Catalyst
for her decision to to begin speaking
openly about it and the first time she
spoke was in indeed on Venezuelan
television
TV station in Venezuela so that was the
um that was the first time she spoke
about it
since then she's been on four trips on
the peace boat and visited many
different countries and um being able to
have the opportunity to speak about her
experiences all over the world
how do you
think I'd like to say uh thank you for
the work that you do it's important
and also it was delightful to see your
art
which
challenges the mind I think to
understand it fully I didn't know that
John Hersey taught at Yale
and for those of you who are two
generations younger than I am I commend
his book Hiroshima to you he did uh
the research he was a journalist also
and he did the research in the book was
Publishers published I think in 46 or
47.
and it uh
doesn't self-pedal but it's grisly
at times to understand what happened
he also wrote a book called a bell
foradano which won a Pulitzer Prize and
as a happier War
so maybe rate that after you read
Hiroshima
foreign
uh so uh John Hussey's grandson actually
um has uh visited her and spent time
they have a connection
um and uh he actually recent this is me
adding this I'm sorry but he made a
documentary film a few years ago also
about
um
peace education and the the experience
of people like tanakasan
so the Hersey connection is an important
one
so she's very happy to hear that he's
remembered here too
this book
thank you very much I found it very very
touching I'm curious about how the
disasters that struck Japan Hiroshima
Nagasaki how they're treated
in the classroom
um
I and what what's age-appropriate in
Japan for the teaching of this history
as the American historian David
McCullough said Americans aren't
particularly good at their history and
uh
I'm not sure how many Americans are
aware of what happened to Japan thank
you
I know
isn't it so foreign
um so for six years after the war it was
prohibited to discuss
um what had happened and then in the
1950s there was gradually the beginnings
of some
um educational efforts around
the bombings
um but recently there's been yet more
change and partly as a result of the war
in Ukraine and Russians Russia's
Invasion there's now an effort
domestically in Japan to kind of
help to encourage Ordinary People to con
to open up to the possibility of Japan
becoming a nuclear power and arming
um and so the the struggles over these
issues continue within Japan
um and have shifted backwards and
forwards but in the current moment
um various things have happened that are
quite concerning including for example
one of the most important um
post-war comic books is called Barefoot
Gan and it tells the story of what
happened in Hiroshima from the
perspective of a boy and his family
and recently the that the teaching of
that book has been become very
controversial so it was used in schools
in the past but recently
um in Hiroshima they've said that
they're not going to use it in schools
anymore
um so these things are domestically in
Japan too always being contested and
disputed and things go backwards and
forwards
a change of government it seems to shift
first of all thank you so much for
sharing your story I feel really lucky
to be able to hear it I was lucky enough
to visit Hiroshima last month on a study
abroad and saw the museum there
and
was saddened and inspired by it in a way
that I feel I never could be at any such
Museum here in the US so I'm wondering
from you what's the best way that we can
share your story here in the U.S
the generations to come
[Music]
Russian
so that
is
I know
Aristotle
ideas
so um as a result of Putin's invasion of
Ukraine
um
it the current moment is one in which
these issues have become so much more
difficult to discuss and
certainly people in Japan and elsewhere
who say
um that uh the kind of people who talk
about abolishing nuclear weapons are the
kind of people who won't fight and will
just run away they're cowards
um but from the perspective of hibacha
somebody who lived through the
experience of being bombed
um with nuclear weapons
um
her position is that the true hero is
somebody who doesn't fight refuses to
kill and insists on talking and talking
through
the problem until there's a resolution
uh
hello thank you very much for sharing
this story during the talk to nakasan
you mentioned uh that one of the ways to
potentially avoid future nuclear
conflicts is for empathy between people
and I just wanted to hear your thoughts
on if you had any ideas on how you might
go about seeing more empathy in the
world and particularly following your
efforts on the peace boat and other
peace building activities
thank you
[Music]
um
foreign
I know
this is
um so as she mentioned her main speech
um she thinks about
um the world as a kind of tiny place in
a huge Universe
um but one in which we are all on board
together as crew members on this kind of
ship
and if the crew members on a ship start
fighting with each other about who the
food or who gets the best broom then
it's an inev it's inevitable that the
ship will go off course
and when that happens everyone dies
so from her point of view the current
moment we're in is a turning point where
those
possibilities are becoming more and more
pronounced
and so she encourages us all to think
about that reality
um
[Music]
oh and and use your imaginations to
think about
things in that way so as to prevent uh
the terrible outcomes that are likely to
occur otherwise
foreign
[Music]
um so she has very high hopes for all of
the brilliant Yale students out there
she obviously hasn't met you I'm just
kidding
no for all of you she has very high
hopes that
um that you will work towards achieving
um a better more sustainable world one
in which people do indeed speak to each
other rather than fighting uh with each
other when there are problems
so if there's one more question anybody
has yeah then
thank you so much of course for speaking
to us today
um of course uh like it's important you
realize that it's important that you
share this story so that it's not
repeated in the world again
um but what I wanted to ask was that how
after a life of
um choosing to not speak of this uh do
you balance and take care of yourself
reliving it so that other people don't
have to while also not sort of
traumatizing yourself over and over
again and reliving it so how do you
um make that balance in your head and
take care of yourself while also
speaking on the story to make sure that
other people don't have to go through
the same thing again
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so you
know
since
I know
so she said it's an extremely good
question
um and
um that it is really hard to talk about
these uh experiences
but she says recently her feelings have
started to change and that she's buoyed
by the possibility that by speaking
about the
it may actually lead to some positive
change and move the world even if it's
ever so slightly in the direction of
abandoning nuclear weapons and the as
I'm sure many of you know the G7 meeting
will be taking place in Hiroshima fairly
soon and she's really hopeful that maybe
just maybe the leaders at that
conference will be inspired by their
visit to Hiroshima and take some action
to address this profound problem
United
States is
she wants you to know that there are
many people who die having experienced
what happened in Hiroshima without ever
being able to speak about it
so she has a friend who uh whose
marriage basically fell apart you I mean
it was a she wasn't able to get married
because
um
she'd been
irradiated
and she remained single for her entire
life she's now 85 and she
was moved into a psychiatric home
and and died there
and she was never in her entire life
able to speak about what had happened to
her
during the bombing so um so because of
that uh tanakasan feels as though she
needs to speak
um
so that he
[Music]
please join with me in thanking again
for this incredible speech
oh I'm sorry one last question hi thank
you for the and very uninspiring talk um
I'm gonna
[Music]
um um
she would like to know what you're
eating during the uh time World War II
because she has a grandma in here in
Tokyo
um her grandma is originally from
Hiroshima and she has heard a story from
her grandma saying that she had a hard
time eating during the war and she just
had so many struggles going through the
work period so um my daughter would like
to know what it was like living during
that time and eating during that time
um
I know
or this is
foreign
[Music]
she said that
um there really was nothing to eat
during the war and so people were eating
the grass from the side of the road
and because the grass from the side of
the road was irradiated when the bomb
was dropped
lots of people died as a result of
ingesting the irradiated Weeds on the
side of the road
then after the war
um food started to arrived from America
and
um that included things like soybeans
that had been squeezed of their oil but
even eating that actually tasted
wonderful after having had no food for
so long people were truly starving so
um it's a really wonderful question and
thank you foreign
okay thank you please join with me for a
last time in thanking talakasam for her
wonderful inspiring talk
[Music]